it's a pool HEV comm exclusive power
98.3 where five lives Ready Set Radio we
got a special guests in studio right now
with me we got Chuck Inglish
one of the most producers in my opinion
we have gots the homie Vick representing
kids these days say hello to was cracked
it was cracked and we have got my dude
Natalie Smith of hip-hop the Alex Smith
about 6 & 2 going into the bye week oh
man y'all destroyed our car knows what
we're like I think Alex was like 18 for
19 yeah so we got actual you know like
that two years ago y'all wanted to get
rid of hash or y'all want to give it out
hey so you guys are all on tour together
ash what's the name of the tour this is
a Fall Classic tours kind of just coming
to classic I mean these dudes next to me
it's just honestly a hotter like we all
work together we hang roll like let's
hit the road and you guys are is this is
this what's date number is this we're
all four so we're just getting into my
voices already shot it's chowder yes for
well the USC thing didn't work out
because they shouldn't okay shut us down
but um we go to Albuquerque tomorrow and
then we head through Texas and then
Boulder Colorado which is super fun and
stuff like that trucks got convertibles
coming out picking kids these days just
drop trap house Rock bananas so
everything simple relevant fun I got a
new record coming out I can't tell you
exactly when I can't tell you the name
of it but yeah whatever happened is this
too orange
man oh it's just like we've been trying
to put out a project now for like three
years
so it's just a matter of keeping it
fresh and keeping it fun so like when
everything came out we were promoted for
a little bit and it just was like it
just kind of lost its originality would
they have anything to do with the Frank
Ocean
yeah like when that happened I didn't
want there to be any connotation so like
any other project is right it's like
it's good when things can just
and that project was incredible and I
was like Frank do you think that it's
ready
indeed indeed so uh Chuck Inglish you
are I was [__] off the air man you
are are you still a part of the cool
kids
okay cool kids okay you know how the
Internet's we talking always nauseous
it's just crazy how people create their
own their own story when they don't now
it's telling I was telling you off the
air man I've been a fan of the cool kids
like man homie like I remember when you
guys first came out I feel like you guys
like Asher's guys like you know of you
know b.o.b were kind of like that first
wave of artists that really got embraced
by the internet and kind of you know
what I'm saying
got got a got a lot of buzz from the
blogs and stuff but I think y'all get no
credit when it comes to style like
fashion like I remember the cool kids
are the first rappers I saw rocking the
retro snapbacks know what I think though
then I think everybody knows it's just
like not in a magazine
daga daga well Tiger fans don't know
that though tiger
solder batter take it away from my
sisters did it on a smaller scale that
looked larger hey so I'm not complaining
what do you work what are you working on
man I know you do a lot of production
for like you know like guys like Asha
Freddie is just waiting it's like we're
running the option with it I guess in
the future and which we are in now you
know I'm saying I'm not doing this one
with a major deal or any deal and all I
actually deal myself that's dope the
best way to put it out smart
cost-effective when you're doing home I
just want to show the world it can be
done yeah probably the next project I
just are you guys as a group still
signed to the the green label those that
would school that project we didn't sign
and I co-signed green label willing to
make new projects with people okay let's
talk about record deals let's talk about
record deals after uh you you know man
without honestly all I want to say is
like myself these cats and everybody
here everybody who's watching us nothing
I think we've seen the recent success of
just kind of doing it yourself and
believing in yourself and and just like
believing in good people you know hope
and with that being said it's like it's
great for me to sit back and see cats
like kids these days are Vick and
chucking like that that sticking to what
you really believe in paying off and
getting that reinforcement from the fans
I mean look at Kendrick shot it's
Macklemore to Macklemore exactly these
are perfect examples of people who
dislike stick to what they believe in
and just do a good job and what they do
and people are showing up now and that's
huge for artists like us of course
because you know we don't want to be
artists and ourselves and entertainers
and stuff we have a problem with
authority you know what I mean so it was
though it was a bummer when people were
trying to control what we do for so long
and and now it's just like it's just
great for a lot of a lot of artists and
fans really like standing up for
themselves and taking the power back so
can you potentially see yourself after
going down the independent route from
here on out I mean I don't even know
what that means essentially like to me
it's like I was when I first came out
and everything happened so fast I was
too dependent to a fault like being on a
major label
unless you're activated and you're like
if you're Rihanna you know Justin Bieber
you've got that dead good read and leave
of all the resources in the yeah but
otherwise otherwise you're independent I
think we talked about I think we talked
about this before you kind of said like
when you've got signed you expected so
what did you feel that it make you feel
and then you kind of like fall back but
then you know you said that you had
learned so much from from like like if
you could
about you and you would've did so much
come on groundwork I learned for my ears
right I learned from my peers because
[__] happen for me so fast and was just
like they can't say that just happened
but yeah man it's just like I look
around and I see people my age and
admire what they're doing and how
they're doing it and they make you feel
so comfortable like oh you got this you
got this and then like a couple months
down the road you look around like I'm
no Anita's people and I don't even know
where I am right now
yeah bien and I think that I think that
you can do it at a natural pace and we
do for the right reasons and you can do
it your way as much as they tell you
you're crazy you have no idea what
you're talking about at the same time
it's like as long as you're comfortable
and you're happy where you are SLI
matters yeah you cut his mic off this
guy show you this over you're playing
with your mic always dealing with Rob's
and reducer hat is I missed it what's
this button oh yeah the project is so of
Chicago Chicago goes crazy
I'm very blown away man there's this
group of kids these days there are two
more so we got the lead singer his
name's Vic we got one of the bay I want
to talk to me because you guys if you
watch you guys you guys see a picture of
your group man it looks like a bunch of
high school kids you know what I'm
saying it's a full-fledged bad if you
already heard of these dudes we paint a
picture it's a full fledged band like
y'all got horns horns I mean everything
and and then yourself you spit how did
everyone meet up man cuz it really seems
like you know you guys were the high
school together
you know well yeah I mean we did go
tires go together like four of us went
to high school together and then uh some
other cats went to a music school
together like me and Layden goes
together but he went to a music school
with Nico who plays the trumpet watching
him up wait and just generally man we
were all kids from Chicago Public
Schools and just you know regular stuff
and just being in the city like we're
actually from Chicago okay thanks for
coming up to the line I don't like that
some dope like not like Matt's murderous
musical Chicago like right now all the
young Weezer gathers Chicago something
like rocky fresh like it's like man it's
so violent
Jesus yeah um you guys been being out of
shine man like you know you got guys
like the cool kids your dad like you
know of course Kanye you know what I'm
saying like how much did that that that
older shy generation I have an influence
on what you guys do because I feel like
you guys kind of have like a sound of
your own really when you listen to your
album it's just it's it doesn't really
sound like anything that's out right now
you've been kicking it with the dues
from crucial conflict maybe to do some
crucial conflicts completely and myself
you know personally in so many ways I
just remember you know being a younger
kassian when Chuck and Mikey dropped you
know yeah when the cool kids first came
out that was that was be in Chicago you
know that was mad doping it was
something I was like it was cool because
it kind of gave a bit of inspiration to
other cats you know younger doors like
myself we're still trying to do that
thing you know just to see people that
you might actually see around in person
getting uh getting this light on a
national stage you know it's kind of
like men you know what can I do to
aspire to be up there yeah hey there's
not a lot of bands in hip-hop you guys
got any like props from from any of the
members of the roots you know of course
that's like the marquee hip-hop man
we actually ambushed Questlove one time
man like our old manager our old
managers homie was supposed to pick up
Questlove from like the airport myself
okay you know I'm saying so he told our
manager who told us and I was like yo
we're gonna go pick him up yeah I'm
saying it so we picked them up one time
it just I was right when we were first
making Trap House Rock actually and so
yeah man we picked him up you know
saying just put the [__] just stuff on
and uh you know and somebody thought you
know it kind of just ambushed at one
time bumped it tones it was dope son you
can't deny it
that's true man you got music that's
just like the one thing it's crazy
because the world is so electronic and I
think like for them that's why they
really stand out right now shots of
phony people at work too and it's just
about a matter of connecting with people
on that music level man indeed that's
why this tour has been so ill so let's
just be cash we got the live band you
know straight up kills it yeah just a
lot of shout-out to children oh man lady
promise be long and Draya Basel come on
play play bass and keys with us and just
recognize recognize only instrumental I
know that can actually play the
turntables like a niche like an
instrument nice to come in there good
Nick Van Exel a shadow dancer so it's a
recognized Nick Van Exel
hey yo so we're gonna play let's play
the joint off the traphouse rock the bud
Billiken joint destroys with an Anna's
man we're gonna play it right now that
DJ Madras drop that tray set radio
powered